ce sont des images muettes mais qui en
disent énormément
nous sommes à l'intérieur du restaurant
casa nostra dehors celui qui mitraille
aveuglément ce serait ça là abdeslam
trois caméras ont capté cette trentaine
de secondes où la vie de tous ses
clients a basculé il n'y a pas d'image
macabre il y à cette jeune serveuse de
20 ans qui prend dans ses bras une femme
blessée au bras
derrière le comptoir et puis il ya cette
scène deux jeunes femmes se sont cachés
sous leurs tables au bord de la
devanture
le terroriste les prend en joue mais
aucune balle ne sortira du canon de
secondes plus tard elle se lève et
s'échappe la folie djihadistes aura fait
cinq morts ici 5
parmi les 129 qui était-il ces hommes et
ces femmes qui représentait la vie
parisienne
radio canada raconte la brève histoire
de chacun un portrait et quelques lignes
ludovic bumba mort en héros en
protégeant une amie des balles à la
belle équipe ils fêtaient l'anniversaire
de hoda morte elle aussi comme sa soeur
à lima qui avait deux jeunes garçons
richard amant lui s'est couché sur sa
femme marie d'auch pour la protéger ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal